mein name ist erst mal kurz den
oberstleutnant so laut sein und frieden
bringen nicht krieg führen ist überhaupt
im gegensatz meine erste auslandseinsatz
im kosovo war für mich ganz besondere
man dort wirklich mit all-in pflanzern
weil man dort mit den menschen vor ort
klettern und durch diese rückmeldung
trägt dass sie froh sein dass wir etwas
an
die flüchtlingskrise von 2015 hat
gezeigt dass die ist ein kleiner ort
geworden ist und wir niemals tanzabends
in bosnien oder in kosovo wieder eine
krise geben würde was wieder krieg geht
so die menschen wieder flüchten müssten
dass diese flüchtlingsbewegungen sie
viel stärker und viel mehr auch
österreich auswirken mögen und genau
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir immer
noch dort sind
[Musik]
am koran
das war mein längster einsatz wollte die
grundsätzliche aufgabe der un truppen
vor ort des trennen zwischen israel und
syrien
es gibt offiziell immer noch keinen
keinen frieden sondern es gibt dort eine
waffenstillstandslinie und da ist eben
aufgabe der uno zu überprüfen dass eine
grenzüberschreitung stattfinden
[Musik]
aus meiner erfahrung mit österreich
besonders deswegen gut anerkannt und von
der bevölkerung aufgenommen weil wir
einfach ein neutrales land sind weil wir
einfach keine versteckte agenda haut
sondern wirklich offen und ehrlich auf
die menschen zugehen können und so
unterstützen können damit sie in zukunft
sicher leben können
was man ändern sich dass der einsatz in
afghanistan ein herausfordernder weil es
keinen krieg zwischen nationen im
herkömmlichen sinne sondern eine
unterstützung der der afghanischen
regierung werde bei der
aufstandsbekämpfung in afghanistan ist
die bevölkerung im schnitt relativ jung
und die gesamte hinüber generation
gehört noch nie erlebt wie das es in
turin leben in afghanistan sterben jeden
tag sicherheitskräfte afghanische
zivilbevölkerung stirbt jeden tag und
auch wenn es bei uns im camp jetzt
offensichtlich keine bedrohung gibt kann
sie jederzeit passieren dass wir dort
antreffen werden und dadurch sind wir
von diesen und diesen kriegsgeschehen
das in meinen anderen einsätzen wegen
der vergangenheit gegen ist aber mit
einbringen
[Musik]
ich bin so dass sie doch in afghanistan
bin was mir einfach wieder vor augen
führt wie wertvolle dies und wie gut zu
uns in österreich geht das geschoss
gegen jahrzehnten keinen krieg verkauft
haben
am anfang besonders wie noch jünger war
schwierig zu verstehen warum wir draußen
diesen diesem diesem beitrag mehr zu
schätzen denn wir dort am ehesten auch
wenn wir jetzt jeder für sich selbst
nicht denn wenn den weltfrieden shop
sagen wir stücke dazu bei dass das land
besser wird die müssen jetzt mal ganz
herzlich bei der gesamten bevölkerung in
österreich bedanken weil ohne die
unterstützung von unseren familien und
unseren verwandten und von unserer
freundin wäre es uns nicht möglich dass
man im ausland so weit weg von zu hause
unser bestes geben können danke